freak might deck you alien Fox Oh
you're gonna just clone yourself and
then done the work you would have taken
like no time at all responsibly I'm
gonna take him on a date with destiny as
I feed him into a giant cat and make it
explode these all sound like they could
be innuendos but trust me they're not I
be gay let me tell you that but I'm ok
with it you know not did it take your
peg leg and I don't all go explore in
the seven holes I'd be ok with that
also there's a dildo in here oh really
is that something the noble bear stalks
his prey the common pond duck you'll
never see me coming
you'll never know come on collect come
on collect collect damn it
suck suck like the wind suckling never
mind
so much unnecessary - there's so many
casualties of this okay goodbye Goku
hello we're gonna fight oh oh oh oh oh I
didn't know if I was supposed to fight
you how was I supposed to know I've
killed everything up into this point
wow you are murdering me we'll all my
goodness ha ha
why is my right hand not hitting I'm
gonna cover my eyes all right we're
gonna play this game you ready yeah no
oh my goodness what I'm gonna do all of
these completely blindfolded I thought I
just certain shorts no sharted sorry oh
I didn't mean to get my propeller blades
oh excuse me I'm not doing this on for
I'm legit eval
I'm legitimately trying here it's a poof
gun it's a gun that poof sound oh I'm
such a nerd oh it's like killing them
with love except they still bleed and
die oh it's amazing oh there's the dildo
yeah I'm gunning for it it's uh it's a
big shower me and titties won't do that
for me on camera okay okay
oh it's delineating come on just blow
one of them up whatever what's the point
of an attack helicopter if I can't do
one of them Oh baloney
whoa okay my god what does it do to that
tree
it's dancin they called the old mushroom
cap
and those look very much like penises
I'm just gonna like no one can disagree
that those look like a bunch of dicks
that are slowly shrinking on the wall
like I'm not it's not even close to a
joke here
that is a straight-up dick that is 100%
steadily shrinking shadow of a giant
dick whenever I see it that is
complimentary dick and balls - is this
intentional that's just this gotta be
intentional here because there is
something very wrong about this site
that I'm seeing right here
sorry whenever I see a dick like my
whole brain process just completely
eliminates itself and just goes into
default mode to appreciate what's
happening thanks for watching
all other videos in this compilation are
available in the description so check
them out and if you'd like to see more
in the future please leave a like to let
me know if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more of a daily basis
please subscribe today or if you're
already subscribed share this video with
a friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye